it's been over 30 years since the
original magnum p.i aired its final
episode but it's never too late to
appreciate the lives of the actors who
helped bring this fun crime series to
life for millions of fans from the
leading man to the supporting characters
here's what happened to the cast of
magnum p.i magnum p.i would have simply
been impossible without Thomas Sullivan
Magnum the fourth a Vietnam War veteran
turned private investigator while
sporting an exquisite moustache Tom
Selleck pulled off this role with
panache while injecting his performance
with a healthy dose of rakish charm
though Magnum remains SELEX best-known
role he'd already been acting for many
years prior on screams both big and
small and post p.i he's continued
working consistently most recently as
NYPD police Commissioner Frank Regan in
the CBS cop drama Blue Bloods
outside of acting he manages to keep
himself equally busy in 2019 it was
announced that he was working on a
memoir that would cover his 50 years
showbiz career as well as his life
outside of the spotlight Magnum is still
in a hundred countries and it's not
dated my shorts are dated
they're a little short one of magnums
compatriots in his investigations is the
helicopter charter pilot theodore calvin
sectionally known as TC the beloved
character was played by the now mostly
retired Roger
e Mosely who had been acting for nearly
a decade before landing the role though
the bulk of his acting career ended in
2010 he made a special appearance as
barber John book II on the magnum p.i
reboot this cameo shortly provided
longtime fans of the original show a
sense of amused satisfaction as he
bequeathed wisdom onto the new series TC
played by Steven hill Mosley's personal
life is less in the news these days than
the more famous Selleck but it's
certainly worth noting that at the time
of shooting magnum p.i he was actually a
licensed helicopter pilot in real life
Mosely turned 80 in 2018 and he's now
living in relative obscurity after a
long and productive career hopefully
enjoying his retirement to the fullest
as played by Larry Minetti Rick Wright
was the owner of the King Kamehameha
Club a favorite hangout of magnums
melodye had previously had recurring
roles on other TV series including the
original Battlestar
lactic ax but he certainly best known
for playing Rick a former war buddy of
Magnum and TC Minetti continued acting
up through 2016 including a recurring
role on the rebooted Hawaii five-o is
Nicki DeMarco a star from the 80s who
excels at living the island life even
when it's riddled with crime in addition
to acting Minetti is the author of the
book Aloha Magnum which details his
experiences on the set of magnum p.i
he's also the host of his own radio show
on CRN talk radio and he even once had
his hand in a real-life restaurant the
Black Orchid in Honolulu was she opened
with Tom Selleck and Denver Broncos
owner Pat Bowlen in 1988 before
eventually selling the place in 1992 no
relationship on magnum p.i was as
intriguing to fans as the one between
Magnum and John Hillerman's
Jonathan Quayle Higgins a third he was
the caretaker of the beachfront estate
robin's nest where Magnum led his
leisurely lifestyle Magnum and Higgins
start out the series at odds with
Higgins buttoned up attitude serving as
a sharp contrast to magnums beer
swigging cap wearing looseness but in
time the two formed a begrudging respect
for each other and that was in no small
way the result of Hillerman's fine
acting abilities already a good deal
older than his co-stars Hillerman
brought British sophistication to the
show despite actually hailing from Texas
he started his career in 1970 and he had
extensive theatre experience before that
he notched a fair share of notable
supporting roles in a number of classic
films such as China Town and Blazing
Saddles Hillerman remained in Hollywood
after magnum p.i though he never again
took on any roles that suited him quite
as well as Higgins
he retired in 1999 with his last film
credit being 1996 is a very Brady sequel
he passed away in 2017 at the age of 84
my son was first made on that boat so
thanks to you I'll never see my boy
Gilligan again what's a TV show about
private investigators without an
attorney
Kathleen Lloyd played the recurring role
of Assistant District Attorney Carol
Baldwin a good friend of magnums who
tried to no avail to pursue a romance
with him interestingly enough before
taking on the role of Carol Lloyd made a
guest appearance in an earlier episode
as a
character named Bridget Archer Lloyd had
some notable credits before taking on
the part of Carol including the 1976
Western the Missouri Breaks
alongside Marlon Brando and Jack
Nicholson younger audiences might
recognize her post p.i roles on shows
such as the practice in Babylon 5 our
last on screen credit was in 2004 so we
hope she's enjoying her retirement from
showbiz after nearly 35 years in the
industry check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]